hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
investigating the effect of diabetes on
bone quality via changes in gene
expression of glycation and bone
remodeling markers in osteocytes
i am jennifer woods of labyrinth and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labrut and brought to you
by gibco by thermo fisher scientific
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
rashna vega phd candidate department of
bioengineering at the university of
massachusetts dartmouth rashna you may
now begin your presentation
hello everybody my name is rajna vaidya
i'm a phd candidate in the department of
bioengineering at university of
massachusetts dartmouth my advisor is dr
lamya kareem and we work in a bone
biomechanics lab where we are trying to
understand diabetes associated skeletal
fragility in these patients
uh today i'm going to talk about how
diabetes affect bone quality and how we
can check the uh
or
check the effect of diabetes and bone
quality by checking
the gene expression markers in bone
cells called osteocytes
to give you a background about diabetes
let's look at the big problem
so diabetes is the seventh leading cause
of death and
according to the international diabetes
federation as as of 2019 there are 463
million people in the world with
diabetes and these are the number of
adults from the age 20 to 79 which is
the working population
and this number is expected to increase
by 51
in the next 25 years to 700 million
so we need to join hands and uh try to
address this issue at a global scale but
also at an individual
and a
and community scale as well if we have
to
stop this from reaching 700 million
so what is diabetes diabetes is a
metabolic disease in which the body's
inability to produce any or enough
insulin causes elevated levels of
glucose in the blood there are two major
types of diabetes
type 1 which
in which the body cannot produce insulin
and type 2 where the insulin is produced
but used inefficiently
type 1 generally develops in the
childhood and type 2 is most common in
the age of 40. but if you look around
and you have friends and family members
most of them in their 30s are now
entering pre-diabetic stage which means
it is an increasing problem of younger
population
type 1 diabetes is caused when the
immune system starts attacking your
insulin or
insulin producing cells or beta cells
and type 2 is most commonly caused
because of overweight poor diet and
inactivity
uh blame our pandemic lifestyle shall we
so this year we celebrate the 100th year
of insulin discovery dr frederick
banting and his colleagues received the
nobel prize in 1921 for discovery of
insulin
and they sold the patent for just one
dollar so that the whole world could
reap the benefits out of it
so it's 2021 and
uh
have we cured type 1 diabetes
no but we have come close to a cure uh
we now have artificial pancreas which
can
monitor your blood glucose level as
closely as it is in healthy patients and
that i that we all can say is a bridge
to the cure
so let's look at diabetes complications
or what can high levels of glucose or
hyperglycemia do to our body
so it can increase your chances of
stroke cataract or glaucoma do the decay
or periodontist
atherosclerosis or other heart disorders
nerve damage
chronic kidney
disorders or nephropathy but in the last
20 years or so we they have uh people
have identified an underappreciated risk
which is increased fracture risk in
diabetes to understand the increased
fracture risk we should look at what uh
what what's there in our bone
so let let's zoom in to our bone when i
started my phd i thought that okay this
is a skeleton and there are several
bones and
uh how do we study how the fracture risk
has increased in bone because i thought
that bone is just probably minerals so
you do probably some mechanical test and
figure out what's happening on it
but i was wrong bone is an extremely
complicated structure
and
beautiful with beautiful architecture
let's look at it at the whole bone level
the bone is divided into a proximal and
distal end at the tissue level it is
divided into two types of tissues this
whole structure is the compact or
cortical bone and there is an inner
structure called spongy or trabecular
bone now the cortical bone has a
fundamental structural unit called
osteon
if you look at this microscopic view
each osteon has a central canal through
which the blood vessels are running
and it is surrounded by concentric lines
of
collagen fibrins okay so
these at the microstructural level
it is made up of lamellaes which are
basically
collagen fibrils arranging itself into
parallel sheets which then run in
concentric circles around the central
canal
each collagen fibril okay each collagen
fiber is made up of singular collagen
fibrils each collagen fibril is made up
of collagen molecules
interspersed with hydroxyapatite
crystals or calcium phosphate crystals
and
so it's
organic
uh matrix plus the mineral that makes up
our bone
so this is a picture of the bone
of human tibia that we generally work
with in our lab
we uh
cut these human tibias into small pieces
and then look at the cortical structure
and then you can see the spongy
trabecular structure the central canal
is where your bone marrow generally is
but these are cadaver bones so you won't
see anything here
bone is also made up of bone cells
well
so there are four major types of bone
cells osteogenic cells or stem cells
osteoblast which forms the bone matrix
and makes new bone osteoclast which
resorts or removes the old damaged bone
and osteocytes which acts like a team
leader and maintains the bone tissue by
telling the osteoblast and osteoclast of
when and what to do
so what determines bone strength bone
strength is determined by bone mineral
density
this is a
dexa scan of a patient
it tells you the bone mineral density in
terms of grams per centimeter
square
and it gives you two scores t scores and
z scores t score is um how good your
bonus compared to a 30 year old young
adult 30 30 year old young adult bone
and z score is how good your bone is
compared to age-matched individual so if
your bone density is
between if your t-score is between plus
one to negative one you have good bone
density nothing to worry about if you
have anything between negative one to
negative 2.5 you have low bone density
maybe starts taking calcium pills if you
have anything lower than negative 2.5
you are at a high risk of osteoporosis
so next time you want to check your bone
mineral density you can
look at the scores and tell yourself
what your problem is
uh bone strength is also determined by
bone architecture
or how uh take these uh trabecular the
trabecular thickness the
how big the circles are the cortical
porosity basically
and other uh
subtle features of architecture
bone strength is also determined by
quality and bone quality is determined
by a few things
first is micro damage accumulation if
you look at this long crack within your
bones so every day when we are running
walking falling down or whatever small
micro cracks are being accumulated in
our bone
and your bone is actively working really
hard to fix these micro cracks by making
new bone how is it done it's a process
it's done by a process called bone
turnover
so
bone turnover is when imagine you have a
micro crack cure
so the bone lining cells will be
replaced by are active it activates the
cells and then these cells are replaced
by osteoclast which will then resolve or
remove the old bone matrix
and then they undergo a reversal phase
which is basically just recruitment of
osteoblast
the osteoblast then come and deposit new
bone leading to newborn formation and
then they embed themselves into the
matrix and become osteocytes
so this process happens daily um
and it is what is maintaining our bones
in its proper shape and size and
keeping us healthy
so bone quality is also determined by
mineralization by mineralization i mean
what's the quality of the mineral that
is formed
in your bone and we still don't know
this process
accurately or entirely
but osteoblasts generally
uh
transport these calcium phosphate
material in
through intracellular vesicles which
then infiltrate and deposit the
uh the the the crystals
within the collagen and where they they
grow and change shape and transform
themselves to make a mineralized
collagen matrix so it looks like a very
delicate process it also determines your
very important for your bone strength
bone quality can also be determined by
matrix composition
so how good is your collagen it can be
measured in terms of uh and crosslinks
in your bone there are
uh there's a good type of crosslinks
enzymatic collagen crosslinks uh which
keeps your collagen healthy and gives
its strength and there is non-enzymatic
collagen crosslinks which are formed
randomly and can affect or deteriorate
the quality of collagen
so
quantity versus quality who wins the
race
now type in diabetes is associated with
six times greater risk of fracture than
non-diabetics whereas type 2 diabetes
patients have a three times greater risk
of fracture than non-diabetics now if we
look at the bone mineral density scan of
type 1 diabetes they have low bone
mineral density which might help us
predict the fracture risk in these
patients but if we look at the bone
mineral density scan of type 2 diabetes
they have the same or slightly higher
bone mineral density
because of being overweight and high
bone mass and body mass index so
we cannot look at their bone bone
mineral density scan
and predict the fracture risk in these
patients so that means we have to look
at something else so we have to look at
probably bone quality
so
how can we look at bone quality or what
sort of measurements do we use we can
look at the amount or accumulation of
collagen crosslinks uh the
bone cells or the tissue turnover how
good your bones are at replacing and
adding new bone
and the amount of micro damage that is
accumulated and fracture repair that
takes place in the bone
so in our lab we study of how on how
collagen crosslinks or ages advanced
glycation and products uh affect bone
cell and tissue turnover which in turn
can explain bone quality and can help us
explain or predict the fractures can
take to diabetes patients as early as
possible
so what happens in a healthy bone versus
type 2 diabetes bones
so
healthy bone has everything in good
amounts normal amount of glucose comings
healthy osteocytes healthy osteoclast
healthy osteoblast good collagen quality
uh very few ages and there's good amount
of adipocytes too
but in type 2 diabetes bones the
increased glucose coming from the blood
can
one okay decrease osteoblast
differentiation so
um
new bone is made less new bones a less
new bone is made
more bone is removed all damaged bone is
removed there is increase in the
advanced glycation and products which
deteriorate your collagen quality and
strength of collagen and there is a
decrease increase in the bone marrow
adiposity
and also there is a decrease in
osteocyte density
overall does not look like a good
scenario for your bone
now let's look at what advanced
glycation and products are so in 1912 a
french chemist called louis uh mayard uh
wanted to know how what
makes us so attracted to our food is it
the color is it the taste okay it is the
taste but what gives our food a taste
that makes us attracted to it and he
found out that during the process of
heating the foods in high temperatures
there are some compounds formed in the
bone uh in in the food called advanced
glycation and products and these
give the nice brown color to your food
and makes us attracted to our food
so what are ages they are basically uh
when sugar non-enzymatically reacts with
the proteins amino acids in the food or
proteins lipids and nucleic acids in our
body
can give rise to dicarbonyl compounds
which ultimately over the month period
of months to years can form advanced
glycation and products or ages
now
when the sugar initially reacts with the
protein it causes functional changes in
the enzymatic activity of the proteins
and increases its vulnerability to
oxidative stress
and when they form dicarbonyl compounds
these are early glycation products which
starts causing oxidative damage and
inflammatory reactions in the tissues
that
it starts accumulating
and at the when they turn into advanced
glycation and products it could be bad
you uh
it could cross link structural proteins
like collagen and deteriorate the
quality
just have a look at the skin why do we
think you have wrinkles on your skin
right our collagen is the most abundant
protein in our bodies it's what gives
our skin the elasticity so when the ag
is crosslinks uh proteins are like
collagen
you have wrinkly skin
so
we are not just aging we are aging
sorry so as we age the ag accumulation
naturally increases over
uh
uh
naturally increases but in people with
diabetes the diabetes complications the
the people with diabetic complications
the high glucose or the excessive
glucose in the blood can accelerate the
accumulation of aging thus accelerating
our aging process
so what are the sources of ages there
are endogenous ages that are formed
within our tissues due to the excess
glucose and blood and there are dietary
sources such as foods processed at high
temperatures processed meat cheese
sausages etc all the good looking good
tasting food basically
so here are a list of ages that are
associated with diabetes complications
pentosidine it's one of the um
most widely studied
age
because it is fluorescent it is
cross-linking and it is easy to measure
uh the other height of widely studied ag
is an absolute carboxymethyl lysine
because it is found to be in high levels
in the serum of diabetic patients
and it's a non-cross-linking
non-fluorescence ag methyl glyco glyoxyl
is one of the early glycation compounds
so the earlier we detect ages the better
we can stop them now we can stop them
from forming advanced glycation and
products and glucosapan is also um
gaining recent attention because
it's found to be in higher levels than
other ages but it's not so studied so
widely so the recognitions of pages is
just started to
gain attention in the society and
more people would definitely
more me more people should work on it
definitely as it says in our food in our
tissues and it is causing a lot of
problems
so this is a recent paper by dr dr
nakamu
and
colleagues
where he
where they found the level of
pentosaline and cml in a serum of
patients with diabetes with dyslipidemia
and hypertension so white bars are
patients without diabetes and gray bars
are patients with diabetes so it's you
can see that the level of pentosidine
and cml are found to be significantly
higher in patients with diabetes not so
much in this lipidemia but also in
hypertension
now if you look at what i'm trying to
show here is that cml amount is in
micrograms per ml and pendulum is pico
mole per mg
so cml is found in much higher
concentrations than pentosidine
and there are other ages which might be
in
much higher concentrations than cml but
we only know these two right now
and
he also found they that the level of
pentosidine and cml are associated with
not uh not significantly associated with
long bone fractures okay good news but
are significantly associated with
vertebral fractures and all types of
fractures in children i see a problem
there
so let's see what roles do ages play in
the bone now ages have two roles to play
in the bone a physical effect and a
biological effect the physical effect is
exerted by cross-linking the bone matrix
or the collagen organic mineralized
matrix
which can lead to reduced mechanical
properties such as ultimate strain and
stress
okay here you can see as the level of
cml and pentosaline increases the
propagation toughness and the bone
decreases now propagation toughness is
the ability of bone to resist fracture
okay
or so resist crack propagation when it
induce uh
when the bone
uh faces fracture
so that means that your bone
is
if you have a small crack in the bone it
will propagate
much faster
in
bones with high cml and pentosadine than
in a healthy bone
not good for you
uh it also ages also exert a biological
effect by uh altered altering the
cellular activity by increasing
inflammation which in terms of cellular
activity which in turn affects the
collagen or quality of collagen that is
produced by the cells
and thus reducing fracture healing and
increasing micrograms accumulation again
which leads to reduced mechanical
properties and overall can increase your
fracture risk
so in our lab uh uh like my my work is
focused on and uh studying the
biological effect of ages
uh on in the bone
so
let's look at
osteocytes now osteocytes are one of the
four major types of bone cells
and they are very cool very fascinating
cells
because of their size
their shape
and their location
so firstly 95 of the bone cells are
osteocytes but they're also the least
studied cells
their location which is embedded in in
the mineralized matrix makes them pretty
fascinating but also makes them
difficult to study
they communicate with other cells
osteoblast osteoclast
which means that
studying them
uh by
by studying osteocytes you can
understand how other bone cells are
playing a role
they are the key regulators of the bone
remodeling or the bone turnover process
so they can sense local mechanical
strains they can sense hormones and
control the bone formation and
resorption process by secreting two
important proteins called sclerosin and
rank ligand so when the osteocyte
reduces clear austin sclerosin is an
antagonist of the bone formation process
so more sclerosin means less bone
formation and it also produces rank
ligand which binds to its receptor on
osteoclast and promotes the
differentiation so that they can go and
resolve bone so
by controlling the levels of sclerosin
and wrangle they
maintain the bone tissue by
regulating how much bone is formed and
how much bone is reserved at any given
time
they also play an important role in
repair such that apoptosis of osteocytes
around the micro damage triggers the
bone other bone cells to come to that
locations and start the repair process
they themselves can resolve bone and
increase the size of their lacunae which
is like the purple space around them by
secreting a compound called cathepsin k
so when the calcium demands in our body
increases such as in during lactation
these cells will
join
hands with the other osteoblast and
osteoclast in resorbing bone so that
more they release more calcium into the
bloodstream
and the calcium demands of the bodies
are met so really cool cells aren't
there
so why do we study osteocytes now
uh they are the least studied and the
most interesting bone cells previous
studies have used osteoblasts which are
precursor of these cells to study
osteocyte response for a long time
however uh they recently developed an
mloi4 cell lines but they are still
early osteocytes and do not express or
osteocytic markers
now um dr paula pajavik from boston
university uh has worked in developing a
cell line called osteocytes 454 which
expresses high level of sclerostone
which is a late osteocyte-specific
markers and shows very low uh level of
osteoblast expression markers does this
does it's a mature ester static
phenotype and appropriate for measuring
osteocyte markers to see the only a true
osteocyte response
uh these are some pictures that i just
took from my cells and you can see
they're like macrophages actually with
their cool dendritic processes and they
love communicating with other cells so
if you like leave them isolated they
would extend their dendritic processes
and try to connect to other cells
because i think that's very important
for them to work they join hands
together
and they're very good at networking
so the effect of ages on bone cell
behavior has been studied previously
using um
ml of i4 cells and
uh
that this is the general idea of what
they found so hyperglycemia oxidative
stress energies most people studied
ageis by just incubating ribose with
bovine cell and albumin and making ages
but not the effect of specific ages so
most of the studies found decreased in
bone formation increased cortical
porosity and decreased in overall
remodeling which then leads to more ages
to accumulate in the crosslinks
so
but there are certain things that people
haven't studied like uh
how age specific response differs from
hyperglycemia or oxidative stress and
etc so that's where my work comes into
place
so my overall goal is one to
differentiate the age and hypoglycemic
response how do i do that okay let's
look at what we know now diabetes give
rise to hyperglycemia which in turn will
give rise to increasing level of
ages such as
cml now cml
uh
so ages in general are known to act on
the cell by two receptors receptor for
ag rage and there is a inbuilt
um
mechanism to fight the effect of ages uh
via anti-glycation receptor or agr1
which is just one of the many other
anti-glycation receptors now rage uh
like interacts with age and activates
the nuclear factor kappa beta pathway
which in turn leads to increased
oxidative stress and increased
inflammation
uh
so we can check that by checking the
levels of tnf alpha and l6 which are pro
inflammatory markers now the ager
receptor interacts with he internalizes
it and degrades it and then releases
these small ag peptides which are then
cleared uh from your
uh which gets out from the body through
renal excretion
hyperglycemia itself can
lead to
rage okay my hypothesis is that
hyperglycemia sets the stage for ages to
act on the cells so when hyperglycemia
increases the reactive oxygen species
within the cells acting on mitochondrial
increasing the mitochondrial respiration
let's say
this in turn can increase the expression
of rage receptor in cells which is how
then the cml might be acting on it like
too many rage already expressed more cml
can act on the cell
okay so and now we are trying to check
that how the glycation markers
uh
can explain changes in bone remodeling
and inflammatory markers and so so can
we say that change in glycation receptor
okay uh
if if if there is
if these guys are engaging into the uh
receptors with their respective
receptors
does they have a co-expression
of sclerosin rank ligand cathepsin k or
obg which can explain that they are the
reason for the bad bone quality and
which is why there is an increased
fracture risk okay my third aim is to
investigate whether metformin which is
known to have
an anti-glycemic activity
can
have beneficial effects on the bone
quality by inhibiting reactive oxygen
species or by having an inhibitory
effect on the expression of rage let's
say
to then improve
which can suggest that metformin is good
for people with diabetes so that they
can reduce
or
reduce their fracture risk
okay
so my hypothesis is that osteocytes
grown in high glucose and high cml
environment will have an increase in
expression of
inflammation and glycation markers
contributing to a disrupted bone
remodeling process and metformin will
have a beneficial effect on bone
remodeling by antiglycemic and
antiglycation property
okay
so in one is to first determine how high
glucose regulate the expression of these
markers
and then to determine how ag such as cml
regulate the same markers and to
determine if metformin can
does help in
elevating some of these markers and is
beneficiary for the bone okay
so what do i do i take these cells um
grow them at 33 degrees celsius which is
their uh
uh
subs okay permissive growth temperature
until they are confluent and then shift
these cells to 37 degrees celsius uh
which allows them to differentiate
now i use a media with high glucose i
use 22 millimolar glucose
uh and i use an osmotic control which
has 22 millimeter manitol to
to control uh as a control for these for
this treatment then i have media with
three micromolar cml and a media with 25
micromolar metformin
i used this glucose concentration based
on previous studies
uh now serum cml concentrations in
diabetes patients was found to be 600 to
700 ng per ml which roughly translates
to two to four micromolar so i use three
micromolar cml concentration
and i use a plasma
and i found from studies that plasma
forming concentrations in patients with
diabetes is generally around 20 to 30
micro mole per liter so i found let's
see if the people who are taking
anti-diabetic medications such as
metformin uh
is that enough or do we need more
metformin to
account for the fracture risk so then uh
so
i put these cells and six well plates
and incubate them for nine days
and we change the media alternatively at
one three five seven after nine days
uh we see increased sclerosing
expression so we know that these cells
have now differentiated and have started
expressing osteocyte specific markers so
then we do gene expression by qpcr and
i'm studying for uh the markers bone
remodeling markers sclerosis rankle
osteopathic
osteoporosis
and cathepsin game i'll explain these in
the later slides i'm looking at
glycation markers region agr1 and
inflammatory markers tnf alpha and
interleukin-6
so
just these are some of the results that
have been
that i can show you today
okay so these are some of my preliminary
results
and here i look at or what happens to
cells or
certain gene markers in presence of high
glucose versus osmotic control now
orange bars indicate 22 millimolar
glucose and green bars indicate osmotic
control or ma cells with 20 millimolar
manitol
uh
here you can see this is full difference
which is calculated by 2
raised to
a part of my mistake 2 raised to minus
delta delta ct method and
in mrna expression relative to a house
housekeeping gene such as beta actin
so what what do we see
there is a ten-fold increase in
sclerosin expression
three-fold increase in rank likened
two-fold increase in opg or osteoporotic
urine
no change in cathepsin k
11-fold increase in rage
and a slight increase in agr1
but since i don't have my statistics
done i cannot say for clearly so these
are not conclusions but let's consider
this as observations
so if this is what is happening in the
cells what does it tell us now
okay
don't be scared
so we have osteocytes and osteocytes
produce uh sclerostone
rank ligand and opg now sclerostone has
inhibitory effect
on
the
uh
proliferation of mesenchymal stencil
sorry differentiation of stem cells into
pre-osteoblast differentiation of
pre-osteoblasts to us to your blast
and it increases apoptosis of osteoblast
it also increases perilous modeling in
osteocytes so thus overall it has an
inhibitory effect on bone formation okay
so then tenfold increase means that well
there is ten-fold decrease in the
formation of bone compared to a healthy
patient okay
or the rank ligand and opg ratio
determines how your
bone resorption is taking place so opg
is sort of an antagonist of frank ligand
it binds to rank ligands not allowing it
to bind to pre-osteo class so that they
do not differentiate into osteoclast now
there is a three-fold increase in rank
lag into the two-fold increase in opg
which means that it's not enough to not
allow for absorption
but
it kind of promotes the resorption so
there are not enough or
opg to bind to all the rank ligands so
the remaining rank ligand is now going
to point to its receptor
rank on osteoclast differentiate into
osteoclast and resort more bone
so
overall
and and it also increases okay so this
is what's happening at the level of
uh
bone remodeling that it severely makes
less bone and there is a slight increase
in the bone resorption activity such
that the balance on the bone remodeling
process is disturbed severely disturbed
what happens at the glycation levels
so here we can see that hyperglycemia is
increasing the expression of rage
rage is supposed to be
inducing ages not high glucose so why is
that so one explanation is that possibly
high glucose is increasing the
oxidative stress or reaction reactive
oxygen species in the cells
which are uh which from other studies
have found to increase the expression of
rage
okay some of the high glucose there
might be some cml in it which so they
can induce in it and
increase the accumulation of aging in
the bone matrix thus increasing bone
quality
uh there is no change in antiglycation
receptors so there is no uh
there is no mechanism
uh that is activated to fight the
increased expression of rage or when
they start coming in
so this might be leading to increase in
increased expression of rage can
stimulate nfk beta pathway increase
oxidative stress
and inflammation
and
that also can explain the increased
range is then
sort of
there's co-expression of
increased sclerosis and increase wrangle
and opg
uh which overall has an effect on the
bad
bone quality which might be increasing
the fracture risk so
what is the significance of our research
uh firstly this was the first study to
compare the effect of high glucose and
cml on the same set of gene markers in a
novel osteocyte cell line osteocyte 454
it's the first study to check the effect
of hgcml and osteocytes uh it's also the
first study to check the
gene coexpression of glycation bone
remodeling markers and inflammation
markers
uh so
what's the implications of our study
a result suggests that high glucose is a
major player for osteocyte dysfunction
in diabetes patients severely affecting
the bone remodeling process a bone
remodeling is an important factor in
maintaining bone quality thus diabetes
patients may be more prone to fractures
as they would accumulate more micro
damage which is not repaired properly
no effect on a perilla quinoa modeling
likes as seen by no change in cathepsin
k expression suggests that this
deterioration does not involve osteocyte
osteolysis or direct action of
osteocytes on the bone modeling but via
its action on effective effector cells
such as osteoblast and osteoclast
so
what do we do in future we should
first culture these cells in 3d since
the osteocyte work as a network in
detecting the mechanical and
non-mechanical stimulus then we could
co-culture these cells with the effector
cells to see their effect
in these effector cells
then we could also look at the rna-seq
analysis to look at
pathways that are similar and different
between high glucose and cml uh treated
cells to identify the most and least
affected genes
and then
uh since these osteocytes
are actively sensing mechanical
uh signals in the bone like when we are
walking or when we are running and which
we are constantly active
so
a mechanical stimulation of osteocytes
in in culture is also it's important to
check in culture to check its effect on
bone remodeling and glycation markers
and then we could also identify some
the role of transcription regulators in
uh managing these pathways in osteocytes
in animal models you could use animal
models of diabetes to understand uh
what's not just happening in bone but
how the bone muscle crosstalks takes
place or the bone fat and face takes
place to see how changes in bone markers
are associated and correlated to changes
in muscle or fat tissue markers
okay
and we could use crispr to
block the rage a
rage expression and check for the
beneficial and adverse effects for
development
of treatment therapies
and also very importantly it's all
important to identify other ages that
might be involved
so we need some high crude high
throughput screening method for of
different ages
and check expression of various markers
to see which aegs
have might have the worst effect
okay like an engaging receptors like
rage
okay so the take-home message for uh you
guys today is that reduce your sugar and
age intake okay how do you do that
limit the intake of processed food or
processed sugar
food high in ages are generally fried
and highly processed food red meat fried
eggs butter cream cheese margarine
choose fresh whole foods low grating
such as fruits vegetables soups and
whole grains
choose different cooking methods such as
doing poaching boiling or steaming
eat diet full of antioxidants so if
reactive oxygen species is causing all
these problems
have a diet full of antioxidant rich
foods such as vitamin c
or quercetin which is found in fruits
turmeric resveratrol found in wine so
drink more wine
get moving regular exercise an active
lifestyle has been shown to reduce an
amount of aegis in the body and also
stay happy because evidence suggests
that happiness is definitely
linked to a healthier lifestyle and vice
versa
so
recently
not recently but last year
i got this uh notification on instagram
that diabetes has started following me
okay so
don't wait till this happens to you
eat healthy and start running now
now i would like to uh thank my
committee members uh this is my advisor
dr lamia kareem
uh other committee members tracy
ferreira paula from boston university
who gave us the cell line and dr jaw
fijia
i'd also like to thank my lab members uh
most importantly dharani she is
another phd student who started along
with me and she's trying to understand
what happens in the bone at the tissue
level while i'm trying to understand
what happens to the bone at the cellular
level
and we together are trying to understand
the changes that are having overall in
the bone to explain the fracture risk in
diabetes patients
uh i'd like to thank our funding sources
nih and asbm are rising star award
uh and also for the cell support and
training support that i had received
from massachusetts general hospital's
center for skeletal research
this is a university of dartmouth
it's really cool looking for the
brutalist architecture
uh it's architect paul rudolph you can
check it out
okay on the last one last thing so
how amazing
uh i could i can't stress enough how
amazing are these osteocytes now
what if i tell you that
we
in the near future
if we wanted to i'm not saying we have
to but if we wanted to we could have our
own jurassic park
yeah we could have our own t-rex we
could build our own jurassic perks how's
that possible so dr mary schweizer of
north carolina university and her
colleagues of
this reported the discovery of soft
tissue in a t-rex femur found in 2007
so they found a fossil of 68 million
year old t-rex and
um
they just
took out some sample from it digested
with collagenous and yes they found
collagen in it
what else they also found some cells
that were embedded within this
collagen mineralized fossilized matrix
now
and um they stained it with
dappy they stained it with uh
like
they stained it with antibodies that are
specific to
let's say human cells to
tell us that these are not from microbes
or other sources so they stained it with
human specific antibodies
or like mammal specific antibodies let's
say and they found interestingly that
these cells are osteocytes these cells
do have dna
as seen from dappy stain
so now we have dna which we didn't have
when they made the movie jurassic park
but
fiction can turn very quickly into
reality
as we see from now from space like wait
are we in space travel now what's next
we could have jurassic park of our own
whoa so osteocytes are
connecting are the cells that connecting
that connected me to our ancestors to
prehistoric times and might be the cells
that could make us travel in space and
could be the link between us and aliens
who knows
thank you
thank you rajna for your informative
presentation
now i would like to introduce taylor
thornton the global brand marketing
specialist of gibco to give a few more
words before we move on to the q a
session
hello everyone thank you for attending
today's webinar i'd also like to thank
reshna our august cell culture hero for
her awesome presentation
to learn more about the gibko cell
cultures cell culture heroes program
view previous heroes webinars or
nominate a friend or colleague please
visit the giveco cell culture heroes
website at thermofisher.com
backslash cell culture heroes please
also stay connected with gibco by
following our twitter account at gibco
and our instagram and facebook account
at gif wholesale culture
these details can also be found in the
resources tab
thank you jennifer
okay i'm sorry i think we're having a
little bit of technical difficulties can
you all hear me okay perfect
let's see here we go
i don't know where my uh audio cut out
so i'm going to start here we will now
start the live q and a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you would
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
if glucose is the problem can artificial
sweeteners prove beneficial to diabetics
uh hi everybody i hope you can hear me
so
uh
i wanted to see if uh
like how do we solve the problem of
diabetes in the world we cannot just do
research on it but we have to solve it
at an individual level
and at a commercial level where we
now have artificial sweeteners coming in
so i try to check if artificial
sweeteners uh do increase the age
formation or not and there have been
some studies done on it and it has found
that artificial sweeteners uh increase
the amount of ages too as much as
glucose sometimes more like xylitol and
sorbitol in grease ages much more but
sucralose has less formation of veggies
so there needs to be a lot of work done
on artificial sweeteners to see if they
can be beneficial to diabetes but in
terms of ag formation and
the effect of aging formations on the
bone or in the body itself it doesn't
look that
beneficial or promising
thank you rashna the next question we
have
can antioxidants be used to reduce some
of the harmful effects
uh great question uh i think antioxidant
so
there is a free radical theory of aging
which says that
we are aging because of the increase in
reactive oxygen species within us
so they a lot of people have tried to
work at in clinical trials to see if
people who generally
ingest more antioxidants have
less
ag formation or reactive oxidant stress
within them but the results are not
farm our reactive oxygen species at much
higher levels than the
then like the antioxidants can have a
beneficial effect on it so even if how
much of antioxidants does one have to
ingest uh there's not a proper study on
that so but yes they definitely do have
beneficial effect as
these
uh the the problems in the bone or in
the tissues are caused by the oxidative
stress itself so
definitely helpful
thank you rashna next question here
how can exercise help in diabetics with
higher fracture risk
so osteocytes are
cells that sends mechanical signals as
well
and they communicate with other cells
based on these signals so uh mechanical
stimulation of osteocytes in in vitro
like in cell lines and small animal
models have shown to be beneficial in
decreasing the source so those kerosene
expression decreases when the cells are
mechanically stimulated so yes this
might be definitely beneficial but what
kind of exercise do diabetes use is a is
a question because once if you're in the
late stage of diabetes people have other
joint issues and tendons and other uh
bones and soft tissues are affected as
well which decreases their
uh ability to perform these exercises so
maybe there can be a better devices
created in future that
targets these problems specifically
rather than having an overall exercise
benefit but if you don't have diabetes
yet and if you are pre-diabetic yes
definitely working out more and
exercising increases your antioxidants
in your body reduces the oxidative
stress and will definitely be beneficial
thank you rasna our next question is
is hba1c related to age and uh
does it do increase or decrease and
hba1c levels affect age
a very interesting question and very
important as well because the way they
test the uh
diabetes in people is by the level of
glycated hemoglobin which is the hba1c
levels now
they have done uh correlations between
serum hba1c and ag levels and
there are controversial results where
some suggest that they are
and some suggest that they aren't but
the problem is that we haven't
identified all the ages so we don't know
which ag levels are increased or
decreased with the glycated hemoglobin
so that could be a very good predictor
of diabetes and ag related problems if
we could
find the ages that are correlated and if
those ages are the ones that are causing
more problems
i hope that answers your question
thank you rajna
our next question if albumin and
creatinine ratio uh are are albumin and
creatinine ratio related to ade
uh great question so ages are basically
like when sugar reacts with protein so
albumin or bow and serum albumin as we
test in the cells so these are given so
all sort of abdomens basically do react
with
glucose and increase the ag amounts
and uh creatinine levels which are
increased in the kidneys can tell us a
lot about ag clearance so
when i talk about the agr gun receptor
which actually
is helps in removing these agents they
just break down these ag's and then
these ag peptides sort of go to renal
clearance
so
creatinine levels uh
so they study the amount of ag peptides
for mg of creatinine levels in the
kidneys to study how these ages are
removed in the blood so they are
associated in some ways where it can
tell you about how these ages are
processed within the cells of a body and
could be a good indicator of whether a
particular type of agent is cleared more
or not based on the correlation with
creatinine levels same with albumin
albumin is one of the proteins that
and there are a lot of other proteins
that have more effect but yes albumin is
definitely related to the ag levels
all right thank you so much so much
rashna
looks like that's all we have time for
do you have any final comments for our
audience
uh yeah sure so i mean uh my mom has
diabetes
and she
is
let's say she's post menopausal
or
she doesn't have osteoporosis because i
made her do her bone density scan and we
found that their bones are healthy
but
she was on medications like metformin
and she will switch to another
medication called thiazolidine diets now
that's one of the diabetic medications
the problem with diabetes is that
diabetes medications have a negative
impact on the bone especially pvds and
uh they do severely affect and increase
bone loss in these patients
so
i told him to talk to her doctor to tell
her that
uh my my my daughter studies this and
she told me that okay these medicines
might be a problem and the doctor said
that okay well all the diabetes
medications are actually in general have
some side effect or is bad on health so
one of my aims in study is to understand
if metformin is actually beneficial for
the cells or or bone cells or not there
are a lot of studies which are done and
metformin seems to be safe and effective
and it does help in elevating elevating
some of the symptoms or
risks in bone health but other medicines
needs to be studied in detail and
there's a lot of research that is has
not taken place so there's a lot of
scope for research there
and i've realized that
uh after working for a few years and
these diabetes it has affected
me in a way that now i'm like looking at
a sweet or looking at something and like
oh my god it's everything is creaming
diapers to me so don't do that just
remember that anything in excess is bad
for health so having a good healthy
lifestyle and a good diet can be is
beneficial at any stage of life the
earlier you start the better it is for
you
thank you
all right thank you so much rashna veda
for your time today and for your
important research we would also like to
thank rabbrus and our sponsor thermo
fisher scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye